la diaspora libanaise mobilisés à paris
ils se sont donnés rendez-vous cet
après-midi place victor hugo dans le
16ème arrondissement de la capitale
à près de l'ambassade du liban en france
son objectif dénoncer le système multi
confessionnel mais aussi montrer leur
soutien envers le liban à la suite de
l'explosion qui a meurtri le pays et qui
a ravagé une grande partie de la
capitale
là des manifestants qui qualifie la
classe dirigeante de corrompus
ecoutez-le
alors on est rassemblée ici aujourd'hui
déjà en soutien pour l'ensemble des
libanais qui ont vécu bien la tragédie
du 4 août mais aussi une tragédie
quotidienne depuis maintenant 40 ans ce
qui se passe au liban en ce moment et
depuis déjà plusieurs mois devient de
plus en plus irréel insoutenable à
ulysse enfin je n'ai pas de mots nous
sommes ici on voit des images de là bas
et on se dit mais c'est pas possible je
suis venu pour demander à ces
gouvernements corrompus relais bon de
partir ce gouvernement a anéanti les
bons celles émises et les bons ils ont
tout fait pour détruire les défenses et
je ne parle pas seulement de la dernière
explosion il ya eu le dollar qui est
répliquée a multiplié par dix son pays
y'a plus rien et appelé à manger et à
boire et la plus fiable